Hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo
Also heute war echt stressig
Ich bin heimgekommen
Hab was aufgenommen
Hab das gerendert
Habs hochgeladen
Hab was gegessen
Hab festgestellt
Hab ich festgestellt
Was ich aufgenommen hab
Sackt, hab mir nicht gefallen
Gelöscht
Schonmal neu aufgenommen
Hochgeladen
Hab ich die zweite Hälfte gegessen
Hab das Video freigeschaltet
Hab den Streamtitel geändert
Hab die Videotext angepasst
Und die Playlist
Das Video freigeschaltet
Und auf den Stream angeschaltet
So siehts aus
Habt ihr das Video heute schon gesehen
Hallo Jungs und Mädels
Zell out
Was war denn da dran jetzt
Ach
Ist es der 500ste bin
Oh
Moment ist es
Hab ich mich vertan
Ist das der 500ste win
Hab ich das sogar
Falsch gedeutet
Wenden sie das Spiel
100 mal in frei für alle
Mit den meisten punkten
Sind das gar nicht 100 wins
Sind das 500 wins
Da muss ich mal
Das Streamtitel editieren würde ich sagen
Na ja mal Video Titel
Ok
Big brain
Würde ich mal sagen
Huge brain
Massive
Enormous brain
Mein Browser hängt
Ok
Dann editieren wir mal den Titel
Das Achievement heißt MVP
Wahrscheinlich
Ok ok
MVP Black Ops 1
Gucken wir mal
Was wird heute gemacht ist die Apple Keynote angeguckt
Ok
MVP
Free for all
Ne
Der Typ hat keine Ahnung
Der das in die Comments schreibt
Also hatte ich doch big brain
Und der hat keine Ahnung
Also alles
Richtig gemacht Max easy
Ja Leute habt ihr das Video heute schon geguckt
Wir haben jetzt noch Zeit
Wir haben noch 20 Minuten Zeit und ich muss mal kurz
Auf Klo weil ich noch nicht, ich war weder kacken
Noch pinkeln noch irgendwas
Ich hab Video gemacht
Gegessen Zeug editiert hoch gedreht
Und ein Thumbnail
Ich hab nicht nur ein Thumbnail gemacht heute
Guck mal kein Thumbnail
Aber der hat ein ganz lustiges Thumbnail ausgewählt
Standardmäßig
Das ist ja keins von mir
Das sieht zwar genauso kacke aus wie meine Thumbnails
Normalerweise
Aber das hat er selbst ausgewählt
Vor allem wie der Typ da einfach rum steht
Was ist das wieder für komische Musik
So Leute also
Jetzt noch mal aufs Klo
Ich mach euch jetzt mal ein aktuelles Video an
Für alle die es noch nicht gesehen haben
Und jetzt geh ich mal kurz pinkeln
Hallo Jungs und Mädels hier ist der Max
Und heute habe ich ein ganz besonderes Gameplay für euch
Nämlich meinen 100. Black Ops
So hallo Jungs und Mädels hier ist der Max
Und heute habe ich ein ganz besonderes Gameplay für euch
Nämlich meinen 100. Black Ops
1 free for all win
Damit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt selber nicht mehr gerechnet
Im Jahr 2019
Das habe ich nicht vergessen
Das Game ist glaube 7 oder 8 Jahre alt
Also uralt
Und ungefähr genauso lange habe ich das Game auch nicht mehr gespielt
Das heißt es kam total random
Ich habe auf einmal den Erfolg am Ende gekriegt
Und habe mir gedacht
Weißt du was Max das Gameplay nimmst du
Weil ich finde es ist gar nicht so schlecht
Ich habe ein paar Stunden gespielt
Ich bin auch mit der Zeit immer wieder besser reingekommen
Score ist ganz ansehnlich
Kills wie es haben ordentlich reingebashed
Außerdem es ist der 100. Black Ops 1 free for all win
Ein paar Stunden gespielt
Und ich habe dementsprechend auch
Einige halbwegs brauchbare
Gameplays erspielt
Ein paar richtig nice Gameplays
Auch mit nicht so den alltäglichen Waffen
Und mich würde das mal interessieren
Wollt ihr die Gameplays überhaupt noch sehen
Ich meine das ist 2019, Modern Warfare ist demnächst am Start
Vielleicht sagt ihr ja ey alter
Max wie ein jungen Black Ops 1 Gameplay ist
Ich habe das vor allem auch gespielt, dass ich mich ein bisschen
Besser auf Konsole in Call of Duty
Reinfinden kann, weil die Modern Warfare
Startet auf der Konsole
Gut das ist Xbox, Alpha startet auf der PS4
Aber ein bisschen mehr Konsole spielen
Zack, Panic Knife kann ja nichts schaden
Weil ich glaube das war gar kein Panic Knife
Ich glaube das war ein, wie nennt man das
Ein Absichtsknife
Genau, also wenn ihr die Gameplays sehen wollt
Schreibt mir das ganze mal in die Kommentare rein
Und denkt natürlich auch an den Max
PS Abo Flatrate, auch garantiert
Kostenlos, no scam, garantiert
Was mir aufgefallen ist
Als ich
Wieder ein paar Runden Black Ops 1 gespielt habe
Oder muss ich ein bisschen anders
Anfangen, was mir bei anderen Games auch schon aufgefallen ist
Die ich seit längerer Zeit mal wieder gespielt habe
Ich habe auch letztens mal wieder ein bisschen Overwatch
Role Queue und so ausprobiert
Es gibt Sachen, die
Verlern man einfach nicht
Klar man sackt wenn man einloggt
Nach sieben Jahren, keine Frage, man kann ja auch nicht
Erwarten, dass man in ein Spiel wieder einloggt
Nach sieben Jahren und direkt abgeht
Und owned, ich glaube das werden die wenigsten haben
Aber es gibt so gewisse Sachen, wenn man
Ein Spiel Hardcore gekrindet hat
Und ich würde mal sagen, das geht so ab
Hundert Stunden los, eher
Bis tausend Stunden oder noch mehr
Wenn man ein Spiel Hardcore gekrindet hat
Es gibt Sachen, die
Verlern man einfach nicht, man hat die Maps
Im Hinterkopf, man hat die Game Mechanics
Irgendwie noch im Hinterkopf, ich kann euch heute noch sagen
So die besten Waffen, Perks, sonst was
Kombinationen, nicht dass ich die jetzt unbedingt gespielt hätte
Wobei, die Galil mit Silencer
Übertrieben, übertrieben leise Waffe gewesen
Ist, auch in MP2
Kriege ich die ganzen Sachen noch zusammen
Overwatch kriege ich auch noch fast alles zusammen
Also alle Spiele, ich weiß nicht ob ihr das kennt
Die man Hardcore gekrindet hat, man verlernt sie nicht so richtig
Es ist eher damit zu vergleichen
Wenn man nach Jahren teilweise
Wieder anfängt zu spielen
Es ist eher so ein bisschen damit zu vergleichen
Wie wenn man
Im Urlaub gewesen ist
Und in der ganzen Zeit keinen Controller
Oder keine Tastatur in der Hand hatte
Und sich dann nach 14 Tagen oder 3 Wochen
Wieder einen Rechner setzt oder einen Controller
An die Hand nimmt
Dann denkt man immer erstmal so
Das fühlt sich jetzt aber ein bisschen komisch an
Und genauso ist es da auch
Du fängst das Spiel wieder an und du kennst es
In deinem Kopf eigentlich noch
Aber dir fehlen letztendlich
So die Feinheiten, dir fehlt ein bisschen
Die Reaktion, dir fehlt ein bisschen
Die Keybindings
Welchen Knopf du jetzt drücken musst
Dir fehlt ein bisschen so im Winkel wie du die Granaten
Werfen musst und sowas
Aber im Kopf hat man das Game immer noch drinne
Ich weiß nicht ob ihr das Gefühl kennt
Bei Games die ihr wirklich lange gegrindet habt
Bei Dark Edge of Camelot
Das ist das erste MMO was ich gespielt habe
Tausende Stunden lang
Kann ich euch heute noch die besten Spots, die besten Skills
Die besten Spells und alles erzählen
Kein Problem, einfach Hardcore gegrindet
Und irgendwie verliert man es nicht
Und so ist es
Vom Gefühl her war es in Black Ops 1 auch so
Übrigens Black Ops 1
Finde ich hat
Von allen Call of Duty, da ist er nämlich
Von allen Call of Duty
Die ich aktiv gespielt habe, wie gesagt
Die letzten paar habe ich ja nicht mehr so Hardcore
Hardcore durchgespielt
Von allen Call of Duty die ich gespielt habe
Bisher finde ich, wisst ihr jetzt Bescheid
Ist der Blackbird, auch so im Nachhinein
Ich hab mir das ein bisschen Gedanken drüber gemacht
Der Blackbird ist der beste Killstreak
Vielleicht
Ähnlich geil wie
Einen AC-130 oder einen Chopper Gunner
In MW2, aber ich finde
Der Blackbird passt zur Hunde am Start
Das kriegen sie auf den Sack
Der Blackbird ist einfach ein nicer Killstreak
Einfach weil er dazu anregt
Dass man auch aktiv weiterspielen muss
Und weil er ordentlich platziert ist
Er ist mit 7 Kills, oder
Mit Hardline in dem Fall, ja
Nicht so extrem hoch, dass man ihn
Irgendwie nicht kriegen kann
Und wenn man ihn kriegt
Muss man aktiv weiterspielen
Und nicht irgendwie in der Ecke schimmeln
So wie der Typ, den hätte ich übrigens auf Blackbird sehen können
Und die nächsten
Killstreaks sind damit dann relativ einfach erreichbar
Wenn man das halt ausnutzt
Und das finde ich cool
So einen Killstreak brauchst, finde ich, hoffe ich mal
Im neuen Call of Duty auch
Ich hab mir die Killstreaks noch nicht angeguckt, ich lass mich da mal überraschen
Und das finde ich einfach
Find ich einfach nice, ja
Blackbird beste, ich weiß nicht wie ihr das Ganze seht, wird mich mal interessieren
Aber das ist der Killstreak so in allen Call of Duty
Der gefällt mir eigentlich mit Abstand am besten
So, Killcam, Hund am Start
Zack, in your face
Wie auch immer das Ganze jetzt gemacht hat, man weiß es nicht so genau
Zumindest jetzt
Gleich, zack, da ist der Erfolg
Äh, beenden sie das Spiel 100 mal
Und frei vor allem mit den meisten Punkten
Ich hätte damit selbst nicht gerechnet im Jahr 2019
Ehrlich gesagt, ich hoffe euch hat das Video gefallen
Und an alle Apple Fans denkt heute Abend 19 Uhr an die Keynote
So
Ich werd das Ganze übrigens live streamen, nur mal so angemerkt
Wir machen an der Stelle Schluss
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss
See you
Dann haben wir alles
So, also Frage, gab's hier irgendeine Frage
Backstream, hab ich gelesen, Freund
Ähm, wo ist es denn
Er schreibt
Moin Max, hab mich mittlerweile beworben
Ach ja, ich erinnere mich, genau
Bin durch die ersten beiden Bewerbungsphasen
Einer etwas größeren Elektro-
und Automatisierungsunternehmen in meiner Umgebung
Durch
Jetzt fehlt nur noch die letzte
Bewerbungsgespräch und Gruppenaufgabe
Die Gruppenaufgabe ist richtig räudig
Was die so einen Scheiß überhaupt noch machen
Das sind dann solche komischen Dinge wie
Lesen sie den Zettel zuerst durch
Komplett
Und am Ende steht dann, ah, du musst überhaupt nichts machen
Einfach abgeben
Ähm
Schreibst du dir eigentlich vor Videos
Immer auf, was du sagst
In letzter Zeit schreib ich mir tatsächlich
Ich glaube, das merkt man in den Videos auch
Schreib ich mir zumindest
So ein bisschen was auf
Weil
Meine Videos früher waren schon
Ziemlich zusammenhanglos manchmal
Mal gucken wie das neue iPhone wird
Ja, da bin ich auch gespannt
Ein Apple-Fan, ja
Also, ihr wisst ja, ich hab alles Apple
Und ich hab Steve Jobs und Tim Cook
Überm Bett hängen
Ich hab hier jetzt extra schon
Neben mich, vor allem Tim Cook
Hab ich überm Bett hängen
Ähm
Ich hab überhaupt kein Bett wo man was obendrauf
An der Decke hängen
In einem Fall warst du nicht verpasst
Ich hab jetzt alles hier am Start, ja
Mein iPhone 6 ist am Start, mein iPhone 10 ist am Start
Mein iPad ist am Start
Meine Apple Watch ist am Start
Mein iPod ist am Start
Meine Earbuds-Dings sind am Start
Meine, meine
Was haben die sonst noch? Mein iMac ist am Start
Ähm
Mein MacBook ist am Start
Alles am Start
So richtig
So altarmäßig, ja
Ja, Leute, ihr könnt übrigens heute mitspielen
Und zwar
Das Serious Max hat ein
Touch-It-Bingo programmiert
Was für jeden ein bisschen anders randomisiert wird
Weiß nicht ob er da ist
Äh
Max Exe, Dankeschön
Pog
Piper Review war noch nicht
Ich hab auch noch kein Custom-Rom auf dem Shield-Tablet, ne
Ach, den Standfuß hab ich vergessen
Stimmt, stimmt, der Standfuß
Ja, nicht ernsthaft, also was ich wirklich
Habe von Apple ist
Ein iPhone 6, ein iPhone 10 und ein
iPad, allerdings
Ratet mal was ich mir davon selbst gekauft
Hab
Jan Goe
Q, Jan Goku
Ich weiß nicht wie man es richtig ausnimmt
Twitch Prime, Dankeschön
Das iPad, genau, das iPad hab ich mir
Selbst gekauft, weil
Ich finde Tablet-mäßig
Gibt's Android
Leider nicht so viel Gutes, ich hab glaube
Hier oder, warte mal, was hab ich denn
Ich glaub ich, also ich hab noch jede Menge Android-Tablets
Aber ich finde, benutzt am liebsten
Bei Tablets das iPad
Rein zum benutzen
Was sind die ROM-Komponenten
In einem PC?
Hä?
Ich weiß nicht was du meinst
Amazon Tablets, ja Amazon Tablets
Also, ich hab
2 HD10 Fire
Tablets, oh, es geht
Im Steve Jobs Center
Ähm, der Eichler, Stufe 1, POG
Ähm, also lass mal überlegen
Was hab ich denn
Ich hab Nvidia Shield Tablet alt
Nvidia Shield Tablet etwas neuer
Mit gefixtem Akku
Einfach mal 73.000
Ähm, ich hab
Einen Tegra Note 7
Ich hab irgendein komisches Asus Tablet
Ich hab alles Lenovo
Ähm, Android Tablet
Ähm
Die Fire HD10
Hab ich schon?
Ich glaub das wars
Und halt als Tablet auch das iPad dabei
Also ich hab wirklich
Mehr als genug
Ähm, Auswahl
Ja, Tablets
Und ich muss sagen, rein zum benutzen her
Ist das iPad das beste
Allerdings
Haben halt die Android Sachen
Einen riesigen Vorteil gegenüber Apple
Du kannst damit halt was machen
Wenn was irgendwas nicht standardmäßig so ist
Kannst du es halt unter Android ändern
Und der iOS
Hast halt gelitten, ja
Vor allem was
Im Heimautomatisierungsbereich angeht
Oder irgendwas, wo man ein bisschen was automatisch
Machen will, ist Android
Weil vorne, einfach zu benutzen finde ich
Das iPad immer noch am schönsten
Ähm, Subs
Ähm, und zwar haben wir Chilora
Twitch Prime zwei Monate
Und dann haben wir noch Astflex
Zwei Monate
Im zweiten Monat
Aber ab nächsten Monat Leute, brauch ich neue Subpatches
Und jetzt haben wir noch From Future
Twitch Prime
Aus Apple, Apple
Mit über 10 applying-tages
Also was ist das
Max, wenn der YouTube Player
Anfängt zu spacken, dann switch auf die Apple
Seite! Wir können auch gleich auf die Apple
Seite gehen
die auflösung ändern bei apple
die musik was das denn
kann man hier keine auflösung ändern bei apple das ist nicht design genug oder was
die auflösung zu ändern
ja also leute bullshit bingo wollte ich euch ja noch zeigen
also bullshit bingo und zwar der serious max unserer mod oder einer unserer mods hat
nen bullshit bingo gebastelt für die präsentation ich poste euch das ganze mal muss mal kurz
gucken ob ich das finde
das war irgendwie github.io ob ich das aus dem kopf hinkriege
serious max
html5 bullshit bingo
ich muss mal kurz im discord gucken wie die wie die richtige adresse war
ach da ist es doch perfekt
ihr wisst ja schon viel besser als ich
da haben wir es am start
also könnt ihr alle aufmachen die adresse und wir refreshen jetzt einfach zehnmal und
gucken was da was so rauskommt
ja es sind immer ein bisschen andere sachen
so und ihr gewinnt natürlich
also wir refreshen jetzt noch ein paar mal
und dann haben wir hier was zum ausfüllen
schnell
ok, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
ja, das war gut
nur 499
oh, jetzt kommt
ok, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
das einzige von Apple, was wir bisher selbst gekauft haben, ein iPad
ich glaube, das habe ich
richtig
bei Apple kommt sieben nach sechs
das ist überhaupt nicht mal angesagt
das ist wirklich nicht mal angesagt
ich glaube, das ist nicht mal angesagt
Aber hat es RTX On? Ist doch die Preisfrage. Kann es Ray Tracing?
Das sieht aber hübsch aus.
Desktop Class Browsing glaube ich erst, wenn ich sehe.
Browser verkackt Apple seit Jahren auf mobile.
Das glaube ich euch nicht.
Okay, das ist ganz nice. Vor allem, dass es da ist, wo der Daumen ist. Finde ich gut.
Oh, das ist cool. Das ist wirklich gut. USB-Stick anschließen. Das ist Proc.
Und der Android geht das glaube ich schon eine Weile, wenn du einen passenden Adapter hast, aber das ist nice.
Ich mache nichts davon auf meinem iPad.
Ich will aber 490 bezahlen.
Oh.
Okay.
Also kann man da einfach auch ein Euro-Zeichen davor machen.
Wie wird man Education-Customer? Ich habe noch viel zu lernen.
Eine Unimail reicht? Mein alter Kumpel aus Dresden arbeitet an der Uni.
Also fast. Nice. Education-Email-Link. Oh, nee. Das ist eines der uselessen Produkte, außer wenn man Sport macht, ever.
Stimmt. Das hättet ihr gerne.
Okay. Im Endeffekt, wir haben noch nicht begriffen, warum das geil ist. Das zeigen sie uns jetzt nochmal.
Das ist die letzte Bewegung.
Wollen die uns ernsthaft erzählen, die Frau hat nicht gemerkt, dass ihr Baby jetzt langsam mal kommt ohne Apple Watch oder wie?
Ist ernsthaft? Tut das nicht weh, wenn man Kinder kriegt?
Aber dann mit der Apple Watch.
Das Kind wird sich freuen, wenn das irgendwann in 15 Jahren mal die Apple Keynote anguckt.
Vielleicht ist der Mann der Gärtner, ja.
Oh, Kokona. Also richtig hier.
Ich bin der Blur.
Ja, das geht natürlich nur mit der Apple Watch.
Das war natürlich Beats-Kopfhörer.
Oh, meine Güte, wie sie sich abfeiern.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch, dass sie so einen Typ auf die Bühne holen und interviewen oder sowas. Dann wäre das perfekt.
Nächstes Mal Dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Ja, vor allem die 2 Stunden Akku-Laufzeit oder was das Ding hat.
Der Akku reicht für 2 Tage, dann niemals mit Bildschirm an.
Was, die Hose? Was ist mit der Hose, Leute? Die Hose? Ja, das ist halt betont oben und unten, betont nicht betont.
Da müsste man bei uns ins Rechenzentrum gehen mit.
Wahrscheinlich darfst du das dann wieder nicht auf die Arbeit anziehen, weil du Leute abhören könntest.
Na klar. Na klar, ich werde weniger krank mit der Apple Watch.
Das Einzige, was das bringt, ist, wenn du regelmäßig Sport machst, wenn du irgendwie Ausdauergeschichten machst, dass du einfach ordentlich gucken kannst, wie sich deine Herzfrequenz entwickelt und so. Das ist okay.
Diese ganzen Sachen mit, dass du nicht merkst, wenn du schwanger bist oder dass du nicht merkst, wenn du kurz vorm Verrecken bist, dass dich dann die Apple Watch rettet, ist kompletter Blödsinn.
The new Apple Research App will be available in the US later this year. Now back to Tim.
Thank you, Sambo. Wir sind wirklich gespannt, was die Impact Research App für uns gibt. Es gibt uns alle eine tolle Möglichkeit, in der Heilung zu arbeiten, die Innovationen anbietet, um unsere Gesundheit und die Gesundheit der nächsten Generationen zu verbessern. Ich hoffe, dass ihr es schaut.
Since the beginning, innovation has been the core of the Apple Watch. Innovations that really matter to people from the life changing to the potentially life savings.
Many of these technologies were barely imaginable. Jetzt übertreiben sie aber echt.
The Apple Watch has become the most advanced and most loved smartwatch in the world. And to tell you all about what's next with the Apple Watch, I'd like to invite up Stan Ng.
45 Jaws, Dankeschön, Rich Brian. 500 Viewer, the fight!
The next generation of Apple Watch.
Die Musik ist viel zu laut.
Okay, was genau? Was sagt uns das jetzt?
The new always on retina display in her sleep, so the watch face is always visible. With previous models of Apple Watch...
Aber das ist wirklich ganz cool für Leute mit einem Apple Watch, die sowas mögen.
Das klingt schon mal gut.
So viel kann das Auge noch gar nicht sehen.
Was ist gut? Also das gefällt mir. Ich meine, ich habe immer noch persönlich kein Anwendungszweck für, aber warum nicht?
Moment, seit wann sind 18 Stunden eigentlich ein Tag? Fällt mir gerade so ein.
Ja gut, warum nicht?
Das ist ganz nett, warum nicht?
Okay, das hätte ich von meinem Opa gebraut.
Aber mein Opa hat im Leben keine Apple Watch angezogen.
Und wie krollt das dann?
Das ist anscheinend voll angesagt, ist die Binger jetzt. Ich meine nicht, dass ich was dagegen hätte.
Da wird wahrscheinlich jemand noch vom AliExpress Chinesen im Käfig hergestellt oder so, aber Recycle by ist schon mal dann verkehrt.
Die Klatscher für alles, oder? Es gibt jetzt eine weiße Farbe.
Wo ist die GZs? GZs, Apple Watch?
Also, ich habe zwar nicht vor, meine Apple Watch zu kaufen, aber ich muss sagen, es wäre jetzt zumindest technisch so, dass ich mir es kaufen würde.
Das sieht aus wie eine Badematte, wie so ein Duschvorleger.
Das ist doch was? Was ist mit Apple los? Was ist mit Apple los? Das kann man sich ja alles kaufen.
Vielen Dank, Stan. Ich bin wirklich gespannt über diesen neuen Apple Watch Line-Up.
Und mit all den neuen, wunderschönen Features wird die Apple Watch noch mehr machen als vorher.
Wir haben ein tolles Video gemacht, um nur das zu zeigen, und ich würde es jetzt für euch spielen.
Das ist eine Cringe. Mach Witz.
Ash ruft an. Nein. Bestimmt nicht. GPS kommuniziert nicht mit Satelliten. So funktioniert das mit GPS nicht.
Doch, Max.
GPS ist read-only.
Ich sage mal gut, das kann ich mir gar nicht alles merken. Wir merken uns einfach.
Die beste Apple Watch ever. Im Zweifelsfall immer beste ever.
Was? Ist da jetzt ein Defibrillator drin oder was?
EKG. Der Fuck. Apple Watch mit Defibrillator wäre auch mal was. Kannst halt wie im Battlefield hingehen.
Ja, jetzt zeig mal her. Mal gucken, ob ich mir umsonst einen Zehner geholt habe.
Also wenn das jetzt auch günstig ist, dann falle ich vom Glauben ab.
Welches? Ist das das, was ich habe?
XR. Ich glaube, ich habe einen XR, oder? XR? Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich habe es auf Twitter gepostet. Ja, ist klar.
Dann habe ich einen XS. Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Zwei Kameras.
Hat Mainz auch schon zwei Kameras, wenn ich einen Zehner habe? Ich habe sie doch nicht ausgepackt.
Ich muss mal mein iPhone schnell auspacken.
Ich muss es mal vergleichen. Ich habe gemutet. Wo ist es?
Nee, Mainz hat nur eine Kamera hinten.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich für ein iPhone habe. Es steht nicht drauf.
Da steht einfach nur iPhone drauf. Und es ist schwarz.
Ich habe einen XR. Okay, ich habe einen XR. Ihr wisst es besser als ich. Nice. Good Job.
GG. Was?
Soundexperience. Dass die Leute in der Bahn noch besser Haftbefehl hören können.
Okay.
Ich schaue es nicht. Ich fühle mich gleich wie am Strand.
Ach, die zweite Kamera ist white oder was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wo soll ich das wissen? Mein iPhone hat nur eine Kamera.
Okay.
Excellent.
Perfect.
Sie können so ein wunderschönes Studio-Qualität-Portrait aus einer sehr normalen Hintergrund herunternehmen.
Alles klar, wir sprechen jetzt über Night Mode.
Dies ist für sehr niedrige, leichte Umgebung, wie im Ausland bei Nacht oder im geheimen Restaurant.
Und Night Mode kommt automatisch an, wenn es zu dunkel ist, um Fotos zu schärfen und den Geräusch zu reduzieren.
Hier ist ein Bild mit Night Mode aufgeschaltet.
Aha.
Ich bin skeptisch, ob das so ausschaut, weil ich finde, die Lampe rechts sieht auch viel heller aus, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut funktioniert.
Okay, gibt's schon.
Aha, okay.
Komm, jetzt Beats-Lautsprecher.
Das ist das neue Apple-Auto.
iCar.
Das Video ist nicht synchron, oder?
Jetzt ist es wieder synchron.
Man muss sagen, in den letzten Jahren hat es da wirklich viel getan.
Die Bilder von einem Smartphone sehen mittlerweile wirklich saumäßig gut aus.
Das ist Quick Take.
Das Video scheint wirklich auf dem iPhone 11.
Das liegt wer fest? Apple, oder was? Ich leg auch fest, Max macht die besten YouTube-Videos.
Ach, das hat einen Blitz jetzt, okay.
Triple Selfie, wobei das ist dann kein Selfie mehr.
Oh, noch ein Video. Let's go.
Was zum Teufel geht jetzt ab?
Aha, das ist für die Instagram-Grills, die sich fotografieren müssen.
Natürlich, bis in den Android-Bash sind wir gut.
Aber die Apple-CPUs sind wirklich extrem gut.
Diese Statistiken traue ich ja erstmal nicht über den Weg.
Ich glaube das. Es ist nicht so, dass ich Ihnen das pauschal nicht glauben würde, weil die Apple-CPUs sind wirklich gut.
Aber ich hätte gerne mal einen unabhängigen Benchmark.
Hatschi, Taku, Dankeschön.
Da kann ich Frogger im 8K spielen.
Die Frage ist, kann die GPU wenigstens RTX on?
Asia-RPG, damit gekrindet, sage ich euch.
Der Mobile-Bedienung. Kack-Touch-Bedienung, ey.
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein Game, das gar nicht übel ist und sich mit dem Controller tausendmal besser spielen würde.
Loot-Kampfsystem.
Aber wenn ich denke, die Leute sehen jetzt wieder was. Warum sieht ihr nichts?
Also ich glaube mit Controller wäre das besser.
Anti-Aliasing, Froggers, das ist ja, doch das gibt es ja noch gar nichts sonst.
Nie da gewesen. Und Bloom braucht kein Mensch.
Kommt jetzt God of War.
Ja gut. Ich will halt mobil gar nichts spielen, ehrlich gesagt.
Das einzige, was ich mobil spiele ist ab und zu mal Hotstone.
Kann man darauf auch Diablo Mobile spielen dann?
Mehr Akku ist immer gut.
Eine Stunde mehr, wahrscheinlich bei Nichtstun.
Ja, der Witzige ist, dass es noch nicht mal fertig standardisiert ist und alle machen es schon.
Oh Leute, ich muss mal aufs Klo, aber das geht jetzt nicht.
Die Musik, Alter.
Nicht Brumpy Cat.
Alter, die Musik.
Zwei Meter für 30 Minuten.
Also kann man mit, ich kann jetzt duschen gehen mit meinem iPhone.
Huge.
Dann kann ich Twitch, Streams gucken oder duschen.
Das ist wirklich, das ist noch was.
Wenn das klappt, wäre das mega geil.
Ich mache das jetzt immer so, dass ich mein Tablet vor die Duschwand hänge, vor die Glaswand.
Ja, damit ich mir Gamergrills angucken kann.
Alter, ist das laut.
Was ist das XR, ist das auch, ist das auch wasserdicht, ja?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Nur weil ich hier ein XR liegen habe, heißt das doch nicht, dass ich Ahnung vorhabe, was das XR kann.
Achso, der mein 6er war nicht wasserdicht.
Das ist, was ist mit Apple los?
Was ist da los?
Warum ist das so billig?
Okay, das fängt an.
Das fängt an bei 699.
Die ordentliche Version kostet wahrscheinlich 2000 oder so.
iPhone 12.
iPhone Plus.
iPhone Pro.
iPhone X-Box.
iPhone Mac.
iPhone Magenta Gaming Edition.
Oh, jetzt kommt das mit drei Kameras.
Jetzt kommt das mit drei Kameras.
Alter, sieht das scheiße aus.
Pro, jawoll.
Huge.
Aber das war G-Bate.
Das war der übelste G-Bate, dass das andere so billig ist.
Das war der übelste G-Bate, weil das ist es eigentlich, was teuer wird.
Gibt's uns.
Nein, ihr nehmt das Pro, weil euch die Namen ausgehen.
Ja, was nun?
Das normale hat, glaube ich, 599 oder so gekostet.
699.
Okay, es hat Tarnfarbe.
Und ein neues Gold.
Das ist unglaublich.
Wer's braucht?
Es ist ein neuer OLED-Panel mit 2 Millionen zu einem Kontrastratio.
P3.
Weitere Farbe.
Einen echten Ton.
Haptic Touch.
Und nun ein viel breiterer, bis zu 1200 Nits.
Das ist unglaublich breit, während es auch 15% effizienter ist.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Okay.
Das geht ja wie nix von der Zunge.
XT.
Mit Displays ist nix standard, oder?
Er hat ganz schön viel geübt, er ist richtig heißer.
Was macht das Klo?
Wo ist Blockchain?
1 Trillion Operations.
Das ist einfach mal so eine Zahl ohne irgendwas.
Was macht das Klo?
Wahrscheinlich wird die AP so grausam sein, wie die iOS-Audio-AP.
Und keiner wird's verwenden können.
Das ist halt so absolut nichtssagend, irgendwie, ja?
Ach, das sind Low-Power-CPUs, das ist natürlich cool.
Das ist auch nix Neues.
Das ist überhaupt nix Neues.
Das machen sogar Intel, und ich dachte nicht, dass ich Intel loben muss, aber das macht sogar Intel-CPUs schon seit 10 Jahren.
Die Apple Watch macht gleich den Emergency Call für ihn.
Alle Leute, macht hin, ich muss aufs Klo.
Okay, Moment, das Alte hat eine Stunde mehr und das hat jetzt vier Stunden mehr.
Fünf Stunden.
Okay, gut, beim Nichtstun, ne?
Okay, dann machen wir mal was für ein Akku drinne ist.
Die ist nicht einfach nur wide, die ist jetzt ultra wide.
Also ehrlich, Leute, jemand, der Pro-Foto machen will, hat eine ordentliche Kamera mit einem ordentlichen Objektiv.
Ich meine, es ist cool, dass die Fotos immer besser werden, ja?
Steht mich denn falsch?
Aber jemand, der wirklich Pro-Fotos machen will, hat eine Kamera mit einem Objektiv.
Alter, so lange, ich muss so pissen.
Okay, dann machen wir mal was.
Okay, ich habe nichts verpasst, er ist immer noch bei der Kamera zugange.
Prä-Tatik, Twitch Prime, danke schön.
Deadplob, Melcrypto, Tokitaku auch, danke schön, Twitch Prime.
Okay, dann machen wir mal was.
Die 13, danke schön.
Ich habe für sowas keinen Blick.
Ich erkenne immer auf allen Fotos, die ultrageil sein sollen, nichts.
Ich frage mich halt, wie ich gerade gesagt habe, jemand, der wirklich Profifotos machen will, hat eine Kamera.
Was?
Maschine-Learning-Foto.
Unglaublich.
Das ist unmöglich.
Ein Foto ist undenkbar.
Haben wir eigentlich ein Foto von mehrher?
Maschine-Learning macht den Strickbrulli besser.
Hätte man jetzt eine gescheite Kamera mit einem gescheiten Objektiv, dann bräuchte man kein Maschine-Learning.
Aber natürlich ist es viel besser, das Foto im Nachhinein schön zu rechnen, anstatt mit einer ordentlichen Kamera aufzunehmen.
Das ist das nächste Level.
Ja.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen leiser machen, die Videos sind übrigens laut.
Übrigens Leute, wenn euch der Stream gefällt, habe ich euch schon erzählt, dass wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime Account habt,
dass ihr den kostenlos verbinden könnt mit Twitch und an einen Streamer eurer Wahl kostenlos subscriben könnt.
Ihr bekommt alle Vorteile von einem regulären Sub.
Es kostet euch nichts.
Das heißt, ihr habt noch genug Geld, euch Apple Arcade zu kaufen.
Oder wie hieß das andere? Apple TV.
Außerdem ist es September, da kostet das Ganze eh nur die Hälfte.
Next Level.
Roaster HD. Dankeschön. Muffinman. Danke Twitch Prime.
Wie ist der Deadly Enemy Twitch Prime? Dankeschön. Nice. Wie ist er abonniert? Zwei Monate. Dankeschön.
Pok. Steff Chris. Zwei Monate. Toter B. Twitch Prime. Es funktioniert.
Wir verpassen eh nicht wirklich was gerade.
Der Subscriber-Sound ist zu langsam.
Aha.
Double PC. Dankeschön Twitch Prime.
Five Head Wine. Musik.
AwesomeKick77. Dankeschön.
Das ist wirklich richtige Five Head Wine Musik, ja.
Mach ein Voting zum Preis. Ja, das mache ich. Wartet mal.
Ich bin immer gespannt, wenn ich Evolution und Filmmusik, Style und Kraft sehe.
Und diese Multicam-Futur wird mir neue kreative Optionen geben, um Szene zu schicken.
So wie ich den traditionellen Schuss-Reverse-Schuss beitragen würde.
Das stimmt, Sean. Wir können sogar diese unglaubliche ultraweite Kamera mit der vorderen Kamera koppeln.
Das ermöglicht mir, die organische und intime Interaktion zwischen zwei Individuen in einem ungebrochenen Take zu fangen.
So Leute.
Ich habe einen Poll angelegt.
Von 1000 bis 2500 Euro. Mal gucken, wer am nächsten dran ist.
Ich habe es bei 500 Euro Schritten gemacht.
Mal gucken, wer am nächsten dran ist. Ob wir richtig liegen.
Das Mindeste.
5G. Poggers. Wo ist 5G?
1500 Euro liegt vorne zur Zeit.
Ja, ich habe jetzt Euro. Tauscht Euro und Dollar aus, ist egal.
Das kostet hier doch eh fast immer das gleiche.
Plus den Dollarpreis, plus den Europreis.
Oder Mauszeiger.
Warum geht der Mauszeiger nicht weg?
Ich habe jetzt abgespritzt.
Ja, wir haben es ja jetzt verstanden. Wie oft wollte ich das noch erzählen?
Das erzählen die jetzt so viertmal.
Hab ich euch schon erzählt, dass das neue iPhone 11 Pro ein Ultra Wide Modus hat?
Habt ihr bestimmt noch nie gehört, oder?
Das neue iPhone 11 Pro.
Ja, natürlich. Ihr seid auf einmal alle bekehrt. Umweltschützer.
Oh, ja.
Das geht doch. Warum ist Apple so billig in letzter Zeit?
Also, billig. Sagen wir mal.
Also, billig ist ja ein falsches Wort.
Ich meine, 1000 Euro für ein Smartphone sind wir doch total behämmert.
Also Leute, unter 1000 wäre richtig gewesen. Es hat kaum einer gewartet.
Ich meine, die Kamera sieht schon irgendwie merkwürdig aus, ne?
Ich meine, das sieht echt beknackt aus da oben mit der Kamera dran.
Kennt man die?
Ich habe schon gesehen Fred Storm.
Der Kaster macht ja auch das Geld.
Threat.
Okay, da muss man auch eine Hardcore-Apple-Fanboy sein für.
Die Apple Watch Studio Experience. Lasst euch das mal auf der Zunge zergehen.
Oh, guck mal, da ist wieder der Badematten-Vorleger.
Oh, kann ich mein iPhone loswerden?
Gut, dass ihr noch ein bisschen mehr verdient. Das ist klar.
Da muss man nicht klatschen für. Im Endeffekt wird dir nichts geschenkt.
Der Kram ist sogar noch teurer.
Ist das der Kappa Pride Store?
Wo sie letztens ein Bild von gemacht haben.
Das ist der Kappa Pride Store, oder?
Aber ich muss mal was probieren.
Er funktioniert nicht.
Lego.
Watch OS.
Die Apple Watch Studio Experience.
Hat es bei jemand von euch geklappt?
Ich konnte jetzt nicht das Bild minimieren, das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, es ist 23.43
Ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen.
Ich hatte, Spitze hatten wir 576 Zuschauer, das ist neuer Rekord, das ist übelst huge.
Ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen, wenn es euch gefallen hat, könnt ihr mal ein Follow dalassen.
Schaut mal vorbei, auf YouTube und Twitter, da bin ich auch am Start.
Eigentlich bin ich hauptsächlich mehr auf YouTube am Start, als auf Twitch.
Meistens war ich auf Twitch, irgendwelche Technik Geschichten.
Einfach zu spielen, wäre auch mal irgendwelche Call of Duty oder sonst was.
Aber hauptsächlich war ich auf Twitch Technik.
Könnt ihr mal in die letzten paar Wots reingucken, wer jetzt neu ist, dass es ungefähr ein Gefühl dafür kriegt, was ich mache, ob das was für euch ist.
Wenn das was für euch ist, lasst einfach ein Follow da.
Und dann würde ich sagen, schön, dass alle dabei waren, wir machen Schluss.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, TU, wir sehen uns.